er klingt mal die erste Frage an Sie wie
groß war ihre Hoffnung vor der Pause
dass sie ohne Streit aus der Sommerpause
zurückkommen groß und dann also
differenzieren Streit ist ja okay
Debatte ist okay aber ich hatte schon
die Hoffnung und irgendwie auch so
diesen naiven glauben vielleicht dass
alle in der Sommerpause noch mal ein
bisschen in sich gegangen sind
reflektiert haben was in den Wochen
davor passiert ist und das ist ja kein
Stil in dem in dem das dann auch Spaß
macht zu regieren und deswegen dachte
ich das läuft jetzt geräuschloser und
sie haben den Begriff fassungslos gerade
angesprochen das war einfach ehrlich in
dem Moment ja ich meine ich stand da
zweieinhalb Stunden vorher auf der Bühne
waren 50 Grad im Raum und vielleicht
sollte man fassungslos nicht sagen aber
das war einfach der Einblick in mein
Seelen Leben in dem Moment weil ich
glaube das nützt keinem derjenigen die
dort Verantwortung tragen wenn es so
weitergeht nach der Sommerpause
also die sagen konstruktiver politischer
Streit ist ja gut aber das was da
passiert ist
natürlich auch dafür da den Blick nach
vorne zu machen ja ich glaube die
kriegen das jetzt auch aufgelöst
innerhalb des Jahres und aber ich kann
mir bis heute nicht erklären warum das
da jetzt genauso passiert ist ich hatte
vorher das Signal es gibt eine Einigung
beim wachstumschancengesetz das war
zwischen Robert Habeck zwischen
Christian Lindner und die Bundeskanzler
das sind jeweils die drei die das dann
auch in der Regierung für die einzelnen
Parteien koordinieren da war grünes
Licht aber verabredet ja wir machen
dieses Wachstumschancen das ist ja dann
im Kabinett gewesen das geht ja nicht
ins Kabinett wenn nicht alle drei das
alle die Chefs sozusagen so ist ich bin
jetzt nicht dabei aber ich bin da nicht
dabei aber das ist natürlich das wo wir
uns eigentlich waren wir wollen das
jetzt SPD und ich weiß von den anderen
beiden Parteien dass sie das auch
wollten und dann passiert was und dann
ist es gestoppt worden
von der grünen Familienkasse ich bin da
nicht also sagen am Tisch deswegen weiß
ich jetzt nicht wer da wie was gesagt
hat aber das Ergebnis war ja das Stadt
der verabredeten Kabinettssitzung wo
dieses eine Tat dringend notwendige
Gesetz was eine eine Stärkung auch der
der Wirtschaft eine Stärkung auch der
Arbeitsplätze hier gewesen wäre jetzt
noch mal geschoben wurde auch da bin ich
mir sicher das wird im Rahmen des August
jetzt auch auf der Kabinettsklausur in
einem verabschiedet so meine Erwartung
aber es muss ein Grund gegeben haben
warum das denn wieder runtergegangen ist
von der Kabinetts Tagesordnung ich meine
es sind ja die Details die das dann so
schmutzig machen und auch so so diese
Fassungslosigkeit hervorrufen also da
kommt der
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
und sagt eine Pressekonferenz sagt eine
Pressekonferenz auf der genau das
Vorstellen am Montag hatte die angesagt
am Mittwoch morgen hat er sie dann
wieder vom Ordnung
also ich glaube das Wort
verfassungslosigkeit ist eine Idee warum
man das so macht das kann man doch im
Zweifel auch habe ich keine Idee wir
haben uns alle wir dachten an dem Tag
geht es um Cannabis weil das war auch im
Kabinett kiffen ging ja durch ne kiffen
gegen durch und irgendwann war dann klar
hoch komisch irgendwie gibt es eine
Verschiebung eine Absage dieser
Pressekonferenz von Lindner und auf
einmal gab es äh
leitungsgesprächsbedarf also die
verschiedenen Ministerien Duden
Journalisten zu verschiedenen
Hintergrundgesprächen ein und dann war
klar oh irgendwas stimmt nicht und
offensichtlich hat es morgens einen
Gespräch mit Herrn Lindner dem Kanzler
Herrn Scholz und Frau Pause gegeben und
selbst da konnte man sich nicht einigen
und wir waren alle auch so ein bisschen
fassungslos was ja tatsächlich ein ein
weit in der politischen Deklination von
Wörtern und Adjektiven ein doch relativ
deutliches Wort ist aber wir dachten
auch das gibt's doch nicht jetzt wieder
so ein Fehlstart weil die Blaupause des
heizungsgesetzes hat der hat mir
eigentlich alle noch im Kopf
und Frau Paus hat inhaltlichen
Redebedarf angewandt oder
angemeldet und dann ging das
wachstumschancengesetz nicht durch was
aber Herr Lindner und Herr Habeck
verabredet hatten Wahnsinn und ich bin
auch dann gab es dieses narrativ naja
wir wollen kein Geld für die Wirtschaft
geben wenn es keins für Kinder gibt was
ja völlig absurd ist also das hat das
eine mit dem anderen zu tun trotzdem
Kindergeld ausgezahlt in diesem Land
auch wenn man für die Wirtschaft
Bürokratien Hemmnisse abgebaut der
Familie wenn es der Wirtschaft gut geht
also die diese chronologik verstehe ich
nicht ich kann für mich sein das ist gar
nichts miteinander zu tun und das werde
ich auch nicht zulassen dass wir auf der
einen Seite den Kampf gegen Kinderarmut
gegen den Kampf für Wirtschaftswachstum
und wir gegeneinander ausspielen das ist
für beides Platz ist für beides Geld da
es gibt bei beiden Dingen jetzt bei dem
einen schon fertiges Gesetz das andere
wird gerade finalisiert und das wäre
nein das ist also das
Ziel nicht sagen
ich kann Ihnen das nicht beantworten
ehrlicherweise
ich kann jetzt auch nur drauf gucken in
der Erwartung dass das jetzt schnell
gelöst wird so ich aber es geht so nicht
Punkt so das geht und es ist ja der
Eindruck entstanden also vor Pause hat
sich ja geäußert dass es nicht darum
ging jetzt das eine zu stoppen um das
andere noch irgendwie zu verhandeln
am Ende zählt für mich dass diese Dinge
jetzt schnell verabschiedet werden aber
der Staat nach der nach der Sommerpause
ist verkauft hatte ich mir anders
vorgestellt das hätte uns gut getan wenn
dieser Staat anders ist und deswegen
habe ich diese deutlichen Worte auch
gefunden und es gibt doch keinen
Entschuldigung für aber dieses Gesetz
ist ja sowieso also wir fing von 12
Milliarden na das für die Kinder
Grundsicherung eigentlich würde man ja
denken Kinder und Sicherung ist zwischen
drei Parteien irgendwie geeinigt
genau es gibt Ideen wie man das
vielleicht von der FDP andere als von
den Grünen wie man das zusammenführt
aber dass da ist ja keiner dagegen ging
ja nicht darum dass man Renten irgendwie
kürzen will oder so da hätte ich ja
Streit verstanden aber Kinder
Grundsicherung aber in dem Fall hat auch
Frau Paus einfach ihr ihren Job nicht
gemacht der Kanzler hat ihr vor der
Sommerpause gesagt so wie so ein blauen
Brief also ich hätte gerne ein Konzept
bis zum Ende des Sommers dann sitzt man
ja eigentlich nach wenn ich mal in
dieser schulmetapher bleibe ist es aber
bis heute es gibt jetzt Gesetzentwürfe
die gerade in Berlin kursieren und je
nachdem wie man fragt kriegt man
verschiedene Auskünfte und ist man
begann im Winter mit 12 Milliarden dann
war hat sie selber gesagt ich brauche
zwischen fünf und sieben jetzt ist man
bei 2,5 bis 3,5 bis 4,2 völlig irre also
ich habe ja Kinder ich habe eine jetzt
schon Förderung in diesem Land die will
ich ausbauen will dass alle davon
profitieren das kann man glaube ich
ausrechnen also ich wobei ich da nur
ganz kurz einwerfen will ein relevanter
Baustein dieser Kindergrundsicherung ist
ja schon erfüllt auch in der Erhöhung
des Kindergeldes und das Kinderzuschlag
ist das sind 7 Milliarden jährlich das
haben wir vor ein paar Monaten
nicht erreicht das ist ein ganz
wesentlicher Baustein das wird das alles
sein aber deswegen stimmt der Betrag
vier Milliarden und nicht weil 7
Milliarden ja schon da also was was man
als Bürger dieses Landes so sieht ist
eigentlich also das hat das Niveau von
weiß nicht Sandkasten retour Kutschen
die war zu mir böse jetzt irgendwie zu
euch böse
also die FDP hat haben die Grünen
geärgert beim beim heizungsgesetz und
jetzt ärgern wir euch beim Wirtschaft
also nochmal ich kann nicht erklären
welche Motive sie hatte das muss sie
beantworten aber wenn der Eindruck
öffentliche entsteht dass das was mit
retour Kutschen zu tun ist dann ist das
verhindern
wir sind gerade in einer Phase
gegengleich über den Krieg wir haben ein
Krieg mitten in
Oberösterreich wir haben eine Situation
das in Deutschland da reden wir auch
gleich drüber dass wir eine
wirtschaftliche Situation haben wo
dringend etwas passiert muss
so und und die Erwartung der BürgerInnen
und übrigens eine
gesellschaftspolitische Situation wo wir
gerade ein rechtspopulistische Partei
mit 20% haben und die Erwartungen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu Recht an die
die regieren haben ist dass die jetzt
geräuschlos die Alltagssorgen der
Menschen klären und sich um diese Dinge
kümmern und da ist jetzt ein falscher
Eindruck entstanden und jetzt muss man
das reparieren innerhalb der nächsten
zwei Wochen ich habe gesagt dass meine
klare Erwartung dass beide Gesetze jetzt
im August geklärt werden
und dann muss das das letzte Mal gewesen
sein dass sowas passiert ist
akzeptiere dass man streitet und dass
man auch unterschiedlich man kann aber
der Kanzler kann nicht eingreifen in
einer Situation wo vorher die Grünen
gesagt haben wir machen das und dann die
FDP sagt wir machen das dann ist das für
den Kanzler doch geklärt trotzdem mal
die Frage wie ist das denn die Autorität
dieses Kanzlers bestellt der ja
offenkundig vorher auch noch auf sie
angeredet hat auf die Familienministerin
und sie versucht hat zu überzeugen dass
doch bitte zu lassen mit dieser Blockade
also in diesem Koalitionsverhandlungen
in den kannst du in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen haben wir sehr
viel über die Frage des regierungsstils
geredet und wenn man an frühere Zeiten
zurückdenkt dann gab es ja durchaus mal
sozialdemokratische Kanzler die haben
deutlich gemacht ich bin der Koch die
anderen sind die Kellner und wir waren
uns sehr einig als wir diese Ampel
gebildet haben das ist eine Koalition
auf Augenhöhe alle tragen gleich viel
Verantwortung und das heißt aber auch
Eigenverantwortung und das heißt ja
nicht dass der Kanzler auf einmal auf
alle aufpassen muss dass er sich um alle
kümmern muss sondern das heißt alle
müssen ihren Teil dazu beitragen dass
diese Regierung das heißt es schon also
wenn es aus dem Ruder läuft muss doch
der Kapitän Ansagen Russland geht
deswegen hat er jetzt ja auch ich meine
hat vor der Sommerpause vom Münstermann
hat das gerade gesagt klar gesagt er
will bis Ende August will er Konzept zu
kinderunsicherungen haben das hat jetzt
nochmal eingefordert
hat ja nicht funktioniert wir sind ja
noch nicht Ende August ich bin mir
sicher dass die Kinder Grundsicherung
jetzt kommt und das die anderen kommt
aber dieser Streit der ist ja nicht vom
Kanzlerin
Reihe entschuldigung aber es ist super
Herr nabek würde ich ja sagen das ist
das muss man dann auf Augenhöhe klären
so kochkellnerprinzip aber dieser Paus
Familienministerin ein an sich geeintes
Projekt wo es um die Ausgestaltung der
Finanzierung geht das muss doch
irgendwie klappen und ich glaube was
passiert denn wenn dann mal ernsthaft
Autorität Vermögen ist wenn man es gar
nicht mal hinkriegt wir hatten es ja
schon dass der Kanzler auch macht Worte
gesprochen hat beispielsweise
Atomausstieg also das war ja da aber das
kannst du auch nicht andauernd einsetzen
kann ich jede Woche auf den Tisch
schauen also ich finde das ist doch
nicht der richtige Stil in einer
Koalition mit drei Parteien andauern das
ist die Eigenverantwortung
auf der Tagesordnung weil alles geeint
hatten ähm und dann wenn es dann auf
einmal einzelne gibt und anscheinend
gibt es ja auch selbst da keine Klarheit
also sie wissen auch nicht was der Grund
ist warum es runtergenommen wurde
teilweise ist offenbar nicht was
besonders interessant weil das muss man
jetzt zur Scholz Verteidigung fast auch
mal sagen dass die Grünen
Parteivorsitzenden überhaupt wenn man an
dem Tag an diesen Mittwoch in der grünen
Partei rumtelefoniert hat nur sehr
wenige Leute gefunden hat die das
verstanden davon wussten und eigentlich
keiner weiß wie denn jetzt das Konzept
tatsächlich was in Meseberg nächste
Woche bei der Kabinett Klausur geeint
werden soll eigentlich da ist und da
befürchte ich wenn man sich trifft und
es ist vorher wieder alles unklar
schlecht sollte man jetzt vielleicht am
Wochenende abräumen
die Frage nach der nötigen
Ernsthaftigkeit haben Sie das Gefühl
dass dass das der Lage des Landes
gerecht wird so wie das da gerade läuft
nein der Begriff fassungslos war ja weil
ich ohne Grund gewählt weil ich glaube
wir haben einfach als andere
Anforderungen und da müssen sich alle
zusammenreißen das ist die Probleme habe
ich gerade benannt sicherheitspolitisch
ökonomisch
gesellschaftspolitisch wir haben viel
größere Aufgaben als uns jetzt über
diese beiden Gesetze zu streiten das ist
wichtig dass beide kommen es kann
entweder oder und jetzt blickt nach
vorne und dann arbeiten an diesem was
macht dann der Chef der SPD wenn sowas
passiert rufen Sie dann bei Ricarda lang
und um mit Nuri pur bei den Grünen Chefs
an und sagen sag mal habt ihr sie noch
alle oder was machen sie dann unter dem
Parteivorsitzenden permanent im
austauscht reden wir über Sachen klar
natürlich reden ich gehe jetzt nicht in
vertrauliche einzelne Gespräch
das Gute ist ja dass wir da wirklich
eine Vertraulichkeit darunter liegen
in der Koalition ja natürlich reden wir
in der Koalition und es entsteht auch
der Eindruck dass das sagt jemand wie
auch wie Jürgen zum Beispiel dieser
Eindruck dass die SPD immer auf der
Seite der FDP steht
ich habe diese falsche Geschichte jetzt
gehört und sie wird nicht dadurch besser
dass man sie öfter erzählt das ist die
Antwort die sie immer geben aber
verstehen Sie diese Eindruck entsteht
nee weil es Quatsch ist also stimmt ja
einfach nicht
Beispiele erzählen vom Atomausstieg
angefangen über die Frage
übergewinnsteuer über andere Punkte wo
wir er bei den Grünen waren als bei der
FDP aber vielleicht streitet man sich in
der Kombination ich glaube das Olaf
Scholz und Christian Lindner vielleicht
inhaltlich dadurch dass sie mal
denselben Job begleitet haben doch ein
bisschen näher beieinander sind als
jetzt Olaf Scholz und Lisa Pause
vielleicht und zumal dieser Pause und
Christian Lindner auch die waren vor der
Sommerpause die als es um die Kürzungen
in ihrem ministeriumshaushalt ging sich
öffentlich unter Einbeziehung ihrer
Staatssekretäre dann auch noch Twitter
Geschichten um die um die Ohren werfen
also ich glaube zwischen den beiden
passt es nicht ist ja auch okay es muss
ja nicht zwischen jedem passen aber
genau dann muss ich doch wissen dass es
nicht funktionieren kann und dazwischen
gehen dann muss das der Kanzleramt
zumindest da machen bevor der Kanzler
einschreitet also irgendjemand muss es
machen das ist in jeder
würde sagen jeder Redaktion so aber das
ist in jedem Team so und das sollte ja
ein Team sein Lindner hat zum Thema
Kinderarmut ja auch noch was
interessantes gesagt dieser Tage wollen
kurz rein
in Deutschland ist die Kinderarmut
deutlich zurückgegangen
ganz ganz deutlich spürbar
zurückgegangen
bei den ursprünglich deutschen Familien
die schon länger hier sind
insgesamt ist in Deutschland die
Kinderarmut aber noch vergleichsweise
und wie ich finde ihn diskutabel hoch
wegen der Familien die seit 2015 neu
nach Deutschland eingewandert sind
als geflüchtete oder aus anderen Gründen
es gibt also ein ganz klaren
statistischen Zusammenhang zwischen
Zuwanderung und Kinderarmut wie helfe
ich am besten den Kindern und
Jugendlichen
hilft man Ihnen am besten dadurch dass
man den Eltern mehr Geld aufs Konto
überweist oder ist nicht vielleicht
mindestens diskussionswürdig in die
Sprachförderung Integration
Beschäftigungsfähigkeit der Eltern zu
investieren und die Kitas und Schulen
für die Kinder so auszustatten dass sie
vielleicht das Aufholen können was die
Eltern nicht leisten können
wie sind die Haltung der SPD dazu das
ist falsch was der Finanzminister da
sagt es gibt falsch es gibt kein
Zusammenhang zwischen Einwanderung und
Kinderarmut wenn man während das mit
2015 ja begründet wenn man sich die
Zahlen anguckt die Kinderarmut gab es
vorher schon in Deutschland die gab es
danach
sie sagen die Zahlen sind also der
Zusammenhang ist falsch ich habe extra
noch mal auch nachgeschaut es gab auch
jetzt gute Presseberichterstattung
darüber und das ist völlig klar
Kinderarmut gab es vor 25 Jahren in
diesem Land und nach 25 15
häufig mindestens ein Eltern gibt den
Migrationshintergrund aber was ist die
Konsequenz darauf also so ich finde das
musst Du sagen den Zusammenhang gibt es
nicht es gibt diesen zusammen manche
Kinderarmut gab es vor 2015 und gibt es
danach auch man sieht kein signifikanten
Anstieg 2015
so und jetzt ist doch aber die Frage was
folgt da draus wollen wir jetzt anfangen
Kinder zu sortieren
wir jetzt an Kinder zu sortieren nach
Herkunft der Religion statt Land keiner
wenn Kinder in Deutschland arm sind dann
finde ich ist das ein nicht tragbarer
Zustand ja deswegen haben wir uns in der
Koalition wichtig auf den Weg bringen
und wenn der Finanzminister jetzt
vorschlägt dass wir uns auch im Schulen
auch im Kitas auch im Sprachförderung
kümmern bin ich gespannt wie die Antwort
ist wenn wir das im nächsten Koalition
vorschlagen
sind anders die Zahlen sind gucken Sie
gerne es gab gestern eine
Berichterstattung der Zeit die haben das
noch mal sehr rausgearbeitet das ist für
Kinder 2015 gibt und dass man nicht
sagen kann 2015 ist das signifikant
angestiegen
2015/2015 ganz kurz man ist 376
000 Kinder im Dezember im dezember 2018
650.000 Kinder
mit migrationshinter ich habe natürlich
dabei also wir können fast doppelt so
viel ich habe jetzt den Artikel leider
nicht dabei aber gucken Sie mal wie die
Kollegen
im Dezember 2010 und ich glaube darauf
bezieht er sich gab es laut
Bundesagentur für Arbeit und es Agentur
offiziell
1,37 Millionen Kinder also knapp 1,4
Millionen Kinder mit deutschen Pass die
sozusagen das bezogen haben was es
früher als Hartz IV gehabt als Hartz IV
bekannt war im März 2023 also 13 Jahre
später waren es nur noch und das sagt er
signifikant zurückgegangen
930.000 Kinder bei ausländischen Kindern
dagegen gleicher Zeitraum dezember 2010
versus März 2023 Anstieg von 300.000
Kinder 900.000 okay aber was folgt da
draußen andere Frage aber zu sagen es
gibt den Zusammenhang nicht gerade
gesagt Kinderarmut gab es vorher und
gibt es jetzt und was anderes
aber warum jetzt in diesem Kontext auf
einmal die Kindergrundsicherung in Frage
zu stellen
dass wir das machen ein konsequenten
Kampf gegen Kinderarmut und ich möchte
nicht aufteilen ob das Kinder mit
Migrationshintergrund sind ob die Eltern
Migrationshintergrund haben kinder sind
die Zukunft und wir müssen gucken dass
wir den die bestmöglichen Chancen geben
und wenn das jetzt in einer Hase wo das
kritisch diskutiert wird jetzt als neues
Argument reingeworfen wird und damit
wird ja die Kinder Grundsicherung als
Projekt als politisches Formen in Frage
gestellt dann kann ich nur sagen ich
finde das falsch finden Sie es
grundsätzlich falsch also will der
Christian Lindner überhaupt keine bösen
Absichten unterstellen und auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht was ich teilweise lese in
den Kommentierung in so einem komischen
diskriminierenden rassistischen Unterton
so ist das nicht gemeint aber die Frage
sozusagen des statistischen
Zusammenhangs und daraus dann
möglicherweise andere Konsequenzen zu
ziehen und zu sagen was auch lösen wir
das Problem wirklich mit Geld oder
müssen wir unendlich viel mehr
Anstrengung unternehmen um dafür zu
sorgen ist diese Kinder so gute
Möglichkeit
ich rede ja gerne mit Christian Lindner
darüber ob wir neben dem was in der
Kindergrundsicherung verabredet ist auch
Schulen Stärken auch Kita Stärken ich
vermute allerdings dass das Argument der
Schuldenbremse dann dazu führen wird
dass wir das nicht ausgeben ja so und
ich finde das Kinderarmut Kinderarmut
Kinderarmut braucht Finanzen und
Kinderarmut brauchen
mit Transferleistung der direkten
Auszahlung an die Kinder man könnte auch
sagen Kinder Grundsicherung könnte sein
ich lasse das was ich habe
Kinderzuschlag der wurde ja auch erhöht
das ist eine Menge und Stärke Schulen
Stärke Kitas das wäre übrigens
einer der mit finanziellen Mitteln
Nummer fragen Kinder weil noch mal die
Frage nach der Ernsthaftigkeit also auch
das wird ehrlich gesagt fast wie so eine
naturkutsche es ist sozusagen Sandkasten
Teil 2 wenn man so will und und ich
frage mich ob das der Lage des Landes im
Moment wirklich angemessen ist der
Industriestandort Deutschland ist der in
ihren Augen in Gefahr oder nicht
der ist herausgefordert ja
Herausforderung ich glaube nicht dass
der Industriestandort Deutschland davor
ist dass er jetzt kaputt geht wissen
aber wir haben unternehmensleiten
unterhalten aber es nicht in Gefahr
kaputt zu gehen aber wir haben eine
Herausforderung knapp 10.000 Pleiten ich
weiß nur für die Zuschauer
Herausforderungen Herausforderung durch
stromfachkräfte durch Bürokratie durch
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
durch den Zugang von Rohstoffen das sind
die fünf Herausforderungen hat so wir
haben im Juni 200.000 Jobs verloren im
Juni im Sommer Frau Münstermann kennt
sich da besser aus als ich juni sommer
ist die Zeit in der normalerweise
Menschen eingestellt werden
damit derzeit 200.000 Jobs verloren da
passiert gerade was wenn die Frage der
der der Mittelschicht 82% der deutschen
Sage den Umfragen fühle mich der
Mittelschicht zugehörig sehr interessant
da merkt man sind gerade noch mal 60% so
ungefähr das durchschnittliche Gehalt
das durchschnittliche Bruttogehalt in
Deutschland wie hoch ist das
ich meine irgendwo um die 2400 Euro
brutto eigentlich jetzt dann weiß ich es
nicht
4.12 macht netto 2600 Euro das ist der
Schnitt Durchschnitt sein Kommen netto
in einem Land in dem die Mieten
explodieren indem wir im vergangenen
Jahr allein 1,5 Millionen Menschen
hatten die zusätzlich in dieses Land
gekommen sind
von denen wir viele unglaublich
schlechten Arbeitsmarkt offenbar Kriegen
in dem sie versprochen haben wir bauen
jedes Jahr 400.000 neue Wohnungen sie
hängen fest bei wie viel was wie viele
werden
95.295.000 sind letztes Jahr gebaut
worden in diesem Jahr das weiß ich nicht
wie viel dieses Jahr gebaut wurden aber
es reicht in und von vorne nicht es ist
nicht das Ziel der findet aber jetzt
also die die Mieten steigen ja aber die
ist viel zu teuer in keinem Land der
Welt ist aber so hoch besteuert wie in
diesem Land das heißt arbeiten lohnt
sich auch in Wahrheit gar nicht wirklich
weil es so viele Abgaben sind am Ende
das ist dass ich arbeite nicht wirklich
lohnt wir kriegen die Leute die Leute
dazu kommen nicht in den Arbeitsmarkt
und der dritte Punkt
kommt aus dieser Industrie und wir haben
einen Strompreis der sich gewaschen hat
der so hoch ist wegen kaum besonderen
Land der Welt sie sagen ich will diesen
industriestrompreis runter auf 7 Cent
oder oder sechs oder was auch immer und
der Kanzler kommt und sagt machen wir
nicht ja also jetzt eine lange
Einleitung um die Industrie
das ist mir auch zu schwarzmalerisch
viel was hier gelingt und was
funktioniert und was Gutes und ich merke
ja das ist gerade nur noch die extreme
gibt ja also entweder
wir müssen doch jedes dieser einzelne
jeder dieser einzelne Herausforderung
Sie angesprochen haben müssen wir
anpacken ich völlig bei ihnen aber wir
sind gerade auch in einer massiven
Umbruchphase ich habe gerade gesagt auf
diese Phase jetzt gucken wir 20 30
Jahren zurück und gucken genau was wir
damals da gemacht haben als sie sich als
politisch ungebrochen ist als Europa
sich sicherheitspolitischen aufgestellt
hat als es geopolitisch
komplett neue Koalition auf einmal gab
als wir unsere Industrie auch auf den
Weg der Klimaneutralität ja sehr stark
gezwungen haben weil wir wissen dass es
richtig ist das ist richtig ist dass wir
uns Klima neutral aufstellen das sind
Umbruchphasen die gerade da sind und
wenn wir jetzt auf den Punkt der
Industrie gucken
fachkräftezuwanderung haben wir gemacht
planungsbeschleunigung haben wir jetzt
an vielen Stellen gemacht muss noch
besser werden bürokratierbau eines der
Themen den die Regierung gerade arbeitet
ich glaube das ist
die sagen so wenn ich das funktioniert
die Arbeiten da dran und ich erwarte
dass die da Vorankommen aber Bürokratie
eines der der wichtigsten Projekte um
auch wirtschaftliche Kraft zu enthalten
und beim industriestrompreis habe ich
doch eine Einigkeit mit dem
Bundeskanzler das dieser Preis zu hoch
ist ich habe eine andere Antwort als er
ich sage wir brauchen diesen
industriestrompreis als Brücke bis wir
genug erneuerbare Energien haben
erneuerbare Energien werden die
günstigsten Energien sein die werden
können aber als Brücke brauchen wir den
industriestrompreise dafür kämpfe ich
dafür kämpft auch die Sozialdemokratie
Vizekanzler Robert haben jetzt ist es
doch völlig okay in der Regierung aus
diskutieren aber ich bin der festen
Überzeugung dass meine Argumente am Ende
auch dafür sorgen dass wir Strompreis
bekommen warum kämpft der Kanzler dann
nicht mit ist ihr Kanzler ja aber es ist
doch auch okay dass der parteivor der
Bundeskanzler mal unterschiedliche
Meinung haben aber warum kämpft er nicht
mit ich vermute dass es damit zu tun hat
dass gerade auch die Frage im Raum steht
wie das Ganze finanziert werden soll das
heißt die vermuten das reden Sie mit ihm
oder rede mit ihm viel aber ich muss ja
nicht jedes unser Gespräch hier
preisgeben
Geld das Geld was wir für den
Wirtschafts- und Stabilisierungsfonds
zur Verfügung gestellt haben 200
Milliarden für die Gas und Strom
durchgekämpft haben übrigens Grüne und
SPD auch gegen den Liberalen
Koalitionspartner war aber nicht so laut
wie Sachen dieses Geld ist nicht
ausgegeben in Gänze und wenn man das
Gesetz reinguckt dann ist das auch dafür
da dass Unternehmen die in der
Energiekrise jetzt gerade
Schwierigkeiten haben unterstützt werden
können ich bin der festen Überzeugung
dass das ungewiss wird werden kann für
den Industrie ist nicht dieser festen
Überzeugung Marco Buschmann sagt das
sehr klar und ich glaube genau
antizipiert
die Bedenken die Christian Lindner und
Olaf Scholz hat deutlich gesagt er ist
gegen eine dauerhafte Subventionierung
das bin ich allerdings auch weil ich
finde es kann nur über einen
Übergangsphase es kann nur meine
Übergangsphase gehen und es muss auch so
sein dass wir den industriestrompreis
den Brücken transformationsstrompreis
egal wie man die nennt Robert Habeck hat
auch noch mal einen anderen Namen dass
man den an Bedingungen knüpft dass man
den an Bedingungen knüpft dass die
Unternehmen vorangehen
sie wollen den Stefan weil
niedersächsische Ministerpräsident hat
sich hier dazu vor der Sommerpause
gemacht
dieser Strompreis ich will das was die
Experten die sich jetzt auch in der
Fraktion damit beschäftigen ist ja ab 6
7 Cent 5 Cent 6 Cent das ist das wissen
sie für mich ist wichtig dass er kommt
ob der jetzt bei 6 oder 7 Cent für mich
ist wichtig dass er kommt und dass er an
Bedingungen geknüpft ist und wie er
genau ausgestaltet ist das können die
Experten im Wirtschaftsministerium dann
besser sagen
der Kanzler hat gesagt er will keine
dauerhafte Subventionierung von Strom ob
2021 noch was ganz anderes versagter
krieg ich bin jetzt auch nicht hier um
irgendwie den Kanzler zu erklären an der
Stelle aber der Kanzler hat das
Formulierung
der Krieg hat natürlich vieles
durcheinandergewirbelt wir haben große
Hilfspakete auf den Weg gebracht ich
sage ich will diesen industriestrompreis
dafür kämpft die SPD und ich bin mir
auch sicher dass die SPD aber ohne
Kanzler dafür mit Herrn Harbeck es ist
doch aber normal auch dass man
ich hatte schon viele Situationen
koalitionsausschüssen wo wir wirklich
dann auch unterschiedlich reingegangen
sind und am Ende gab es eine Einigung
das ist in der normal und das sollten
doch nicht klein reden und sollten das
ja nicht jetzt etwas Komisches
darstellen dass man unterschiedliche
Ansichten in der Politik hat nein darum
geht's nicht es ist ihre Partei es ist
ihr Kanzlerin es geht um den
Industriestandort Deutschland genau
2021 ich habe das schon moniert und da
gab es noch keinen Krieg in der Ukraine
weil auch da war die Klage immer schon
da das Strom in Deutschland viel viel zu
teuer mit der Ukraine
am Rande zu tun
muss in Deutschland günstiger werden
denn unsere Unternehmen müssen im
internationalen Wettbewerb bestehen
können
darum werden wir die EEG-Umlage bis 2025
abschaffen und die Abgaben und Umlagen
in Energiebereich neu ordnen mein Ziel
ist ein industriestrompreis von 4 Cent
allerdings auch das gehört zur Wahrheit
dazu ein schuldenfinanziertes Strohfeuer
dass die Inflation wieder anheizt oder
eine dauersubvention von Strompreisen
mit der Gießkanne können wir uns nicht
leisten und wird es deshalb auch nicht
geben
die können Sie jetzt den Kanzler
erklären ich habe es gerade gesagt er
spricht sich gegen einen
dauerhafte Subventionierung aus und das
ist eines das könnte trotzdem kommen ich
kämpfe dafür
ich rede natürlich mit dem Kanzler
drüber reden
nee ich ich weiß dass sie das total
finden toll finden wenn Politik immer so
Konfrontation aber es ist dann natürlich
SPD und der Bundeskanzler
unterschiedliche Positionen haben wir
tauschen uns aus wir reden darüber die
Fraktion hat auch eine klare Position
dass sie für diesen industriestrompreis
ist und wir müssen jetzt bis zum Ende
der Haushaltsberatung das klären weil
die Frage im Raum steht es gibt zwei
fachliche Fragen gerade das eine ist
geht das EU beihilferechtlich und das
zweite ist die Frage kann es über die
Wirtschafts- und stabilisierungsform
finanziert werden ich sage bei beiden
Fragen ist kein Problem und das muss
jetzt geklärt werden im Hintergrund naja
also ich überlege mir gerade was
eigentlich passiert wenn die Fraktion
die Partei sich nicht gegen den Kanzler
durchsetzt dann haben wir keine
ampelkrise aber der spd-krise das kann
ich in Ihrem Interesse sein also wird
man am Ende wahrscheinlich eine
Formulierung finden die dann hoffentlich
mit Herrn Lindner und Herrn Scholz
intern abgestimmt ist dass man es nicht
industriestrompreis sondern
gute gute Industrie minuspreis oder so
nennt das sind ja immer diese schönen
Formulierungen nein ich glaube dass
dieses Thema so sehr Scholz der hat sich
ja in vorunternehmen in NRW dagegen so
gewährt und kam da gar nicht so gut an
also es ist auch interessant was ihm da
so reingeschrieben wird man könnte das
ja auch ein bisschen anders formulieren
aber gut ich glaube am Ende wird es wird
was geben weil die Grünen das auch
wollen und weil der WSF ja da ist aber
es ist schon auch erstaunlich dass man
jetzt so auf den Trichter erst kommt
also könnte man ja auch vorher abstimmen
und das wachstumschancengesetz ähm 6,5
Jahren Erleichterung oder so ist ja kann
ja nur ein Anfang für eine große
Industriepolitik sein also wenn man
durchs Land fährt selber auch gemacht
alle Klagen ich habe 14 beauftragt dafür
irgendwas in Firmen ich habe immer noch
keine Fachkräfte die kommen allmählich
ich kann ja Löhne nicht so erhöhen die
es gerne so oder sind seit 2005 auch das
ist statistisch
kaum gestiegen sagte einer der Gründe
warum die Mittelschicht so langsam aber
sicher auch in diesem Land unter die
Räder kommt und warum die großen sagen
Mensch Amerika ist gerade super weil das
wird subventioniert wenn ich noch was
für den Klimaschutz mache also Stichwort
ein riesen subventionspaket eigentlich
gibt es aber das ja in Europa auch also
ich glaube wenn man eine eu-situationen
und in Deutschland gegenrechnet würde
man auf gar nicht so viel weniger kommen
deswegen ist es die Frage warum kommt es
nicht dezidiert an warum hat man den
Spirit nicht
ja das ist ein Problem das glaube ich
für die Zukunft dieses Landes wichtiger
ist das vieles andere weil diese indust
ohne Industriestandort Thema Kinderarmut
ohne Menschen die arbeiten
drehen wir uns immer wieder um die
sozialfrage und
da wird es nicht besser werden und dann
kam bevor wir gleich über die Ukraine
sprechen und auch die Frage was da
militärisch und politisch gerade
passiert woran interessantes Thema auf
Kollegen der Rheinischen Post haben
interessantes Interview gemacht mit der
Chefin der Bundesanstalt für Arbeit
die zu zitieren ist mit dem Satz oder
sind wir jetzt bei der rentendiskussion
die unzähligen Frühverrentungen nehmen
zu und die frühverrentungsprogramme sind
kontraproduktiv
die erfahrenen Fachkräfte würden noch
lange gebraucht und das müssten diese
Unternehmen jetzt endlich mal verstehen
die Frauen die das gesagt das ist
zufälligerweise eine gewisse Andrea
Nahles die selber diese Rente mit 63
durchgeboxt hat und jetzt fällt dir auf
45 Jahren ja trotzdem dass diese
frühverrentungsprogramme ein riesen
Desaster sind weil sie viel zu teuer
sind und weil wir mittlerweile 300.000
Leute jedes Jahr haben die diese
frühverrentungsprogramme in Anspruch
nehmen Menschen die möglicherweise sonst
noch ein bisschen weiter gearbeitet
hätten und die wir so dringend brauchen
was sagen sie dazu ich glaube
also erstmal ging es bei der Rente mit
63 Jahren um die 45 Jahre aber es ist in
der Tat so dass wir gucken müssen dass
das Renteneintrittsalter das
wie heute haben dass das auch besser
erreicht wird dass wir dahin gehen viele
gehen in der Tat früher raus das hat
teilweise 100.000 pro Jahr es hat mit
gesundheitlichen Gründen zu tun das hat
mit die Programme aber es gibt viele
andere die können auch gar nicht mehr
arbeiten und deswegen müssen wir gucken
dass wir den Arbeitsmarkt so aufstellen
dass die Leute das tatsächlich
Renteneintrittsalter erreichen und das
zweite ist das haben wir auch verabredet
in der Ampel dass wir dafür sorgen dass
Menschen auch danach noch arbeiten
können wenn sie dennoch arbeiten dieses
63 war das ein Fehler sie sagt diese
Früchte
davon weil wir davon Leuten reden die
einfach auch nicht mehr konnten die
konnten nicht mehr doch nicht alle da
gab es eine also gerne mal durchgehen
nicht bei mir im Wahlkreis habe das sind
Leute wo man wirklich froh war dass man
die noch eine Möglichkeit gegeben hat
auszugeben
weil wir heute eine andere Situation auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt haben und weil in den
letzten Jahren viel auch dafür getan
wurde das z.B der Gesundheitsschutz im
Beruf gestärkt wurde Olaf Scholz hat das
übrigens auch in einem Interview mal in
Frage gestellt habe ich letzten Sommer
glaube ich dass die Rente mit 63
vielleicht nicht so ganz
also was passiert denn da ist da ist da
sozusagen ist da etwas
planen Sie das abzuschaffen nein das
wird überhaupt nee das wird nicht
abgeschafft aber das ist in der Tat so
dass wir gucken müssen dass die Leute
erstmal das tatsächliche
Renteneintrittsalter erreichen das ist
das was wir schaffen müssen es gibt ja
immer wieder diese Debatten auch aus der
Union das Renteneintrittsalter noch mal
zu erhöhen und so weiter aber wir sehen
uns da geht's um viel viel mehr als die
300.000 die das Nutzen nach 45 Jahren
mit 63 in Rente zu gehen es gibt viele
die erreichen nicht die 45 Beitragsjahre
und das ist ein Problem das ist auch ein
Problem aber die Rente mit 63 bleibt sie
bleibt da gibt's überhaupt keinen
nachdenken dass daran